avant de dire bonjour à nos invités je
veux juste régler un petit truc mais
quoi il ya eu il ya un instant un billet
qui a été gagnée pour la laponie
je compare en laponie le 29 novembre à
la recherche du père noël pour l'instant
je ne pars pas ce n'est pas été
sélectionné je ferai une sélection
spéciale ensuite si je réussis c'est bon
si je ne réussis pas je ne pars pas avec
vous banda pour l'instant vous êtes
livré à vous-même la peau nue c'est
concerne aussi madame ann mathieu
delormeau avait un instant on a joué un
jeu il fallait choisir des sièges
il y avait un siège gagnants c'était le
7 et matthieu delormeau avait choisi le
8 au départ et je sais pas pourquoi mais
ce sera un moment il s'est réveillé l'a
dit je veux absolument le sénat si
quelqu'un a vu quelque chose une triche
ou quoi que ce soit une miley disent
maintenant qu'ils se taisent à tous
jeunes personnes à rennes a dévoilé sa
mère ce qui se passera moi j'ai tout vu
j'ai vraiment allez-y ça m'étonne pas
que par mathieu parce que le seul qui
trichent ici bas c'est toi et voilà
merci ce que j'explique non pas du tout
ça bout de ton argument s'il ne reprend
jamais en fait c'était toujours le même
fidèle à toi même il ya quelqu'un
derrière la caméra qui a fait des gestes
avec ses mains non je ne peux pas vous
dire qui est ce ac-v chabot sa tête
était fier un petit peu je me rappelle
alors c'est la seule personne qui
foulent des néons vrai c'est quand même
fou servir la mentalité me de la
personne je la connais veut bien coup
car j'ai un boîtier vous plaît cette
personne a fait des gestes avec ses
mains ce qu'il m'est attribué sa dans le
geste est ce qu'ils veulent plus il ya
eu triche clairement alors ah ben je
vais vous dire la chanson que j'ai
prononcés ces stats en effet tout moi je
sais tu t'es dit je sais comme dimitri
c'est tata justice il ya une meuf qui
parle c'est fini benjamin castaldi aussi
a tout vu on m'a dit que vous avez perdu
ce n'est pas un hasard si je me suis rué
sur le 7ème à la ville est riche et
aussi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sauf que pardon sauf que moi à la fin il
m'a dit tu le sais j'ai dit non car j'ai
un honneur gd je resterai sur les
sociétés c'est vrai il ya un monde entre
les chéris les chiots tu devrais je
prendre cette décision je vais
d'apprendre aux 15 secondes aux seins ça
va aller beaucoup plus vite que la
justice
matthieu delormeau il était 19 heures 28
et matthieu delormeau avait le choix
oui il ne partait pas en laponie et y
laisser partir aimons notre ami le
chauffeur livreur que j'aime énormément
on oublie il trichait vont pouvoir
rejoindre ses petits camarades et
pouvoir passer ces quatre jours de rêve
de matthieu delormeau je le suis
aujourd'hui vous avez triché
vous avez une preuve j'ai toutes les
preuves que des caméras partout devant
vera y en a partout
delorme où vous avez triché mais de
leurs mots à
rien mais pas vu pas pris
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
au moment où le savez comme je n'aime
pas les gens qui dénoncent la stalle du
goût et kelly ça vous arrange et bien
qu'on dénonce bon j'ai fait exprès amené
dans un piège et vous y êtes allé les
deux piétons
est ce que j'aime quand on dénonce au
csa non est ce que j'aime quand on
dénonce et petits camarades non mais on
n'a pas est ce que j'aime quand on
dénonce une autre chaîne non à faire
avant d'être enfin non pas de la triche
qu'est ce que la nappe a dit qu'il est
prêt vous avez dénoncé la triche mais
lui on peut le dénoncer mais non mais
non pas lui alors c'est un ami si vous
avez gagné votre billet pour la laponie
mais du débat alors la merci du débat
parce que moi je prends toujours le
numéro 7 parce que quand je joue au foot
jamais vu un numéro de série mais sans
son sac je suis partie son numéro sept
mais je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
alors content d'être là on va pas je
vais revenir peut-être sarde et touche
pas à mon poste mais moi je me retire
officiellement du voyage de la panique
je veux plus y aller en laponie pourquoi
lusaka camou ce mail à l'endroit des
vous inquiétez pas vous j'ai une très
bonne nouvelle fois bien on accepte la
décision très bonne nouvelle les
qualifier de nom mais maintenant nous
placions plaît laissez-moi me parler
raymond non seulement j'ai une bonne
nouvelle pour vous mais j'ai une bonne
nouvelle qui est un espèce de nouvelles
doubles si tu installes doublette
covalence de bonnes nouvelles
les amateurs de chiens non seulement
vous allez partir en laponie
car je vous donne votre billet pour la
laponie mais vous allez venir en camion
exactement
[Applaudissements]
et attendez et vous ne viendrez pas seul
avec des puisque vous allez nous livrer
daniel et sa mère hu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est sûr maintenant j'ai regardé il
exactement 35 heures de route du parti
mais nous par le jeudi où partirais le
lundi je vais me faire chier 35 heures
de camion
alors là je pourrai voit désormais
changer de plan non non non c'est pas
c'est pas du sculpteur daniel compte sur
vous et sa maman au bon dieu merci merci
raymond merlaud